tom brady rookie card sold for
record-breaking 2.25 million dollars the
autocraft 2000 playoff contender
championship rookie ticket
was a part of leland's spring classic
2021 collection
the opening bid was at 75 000 but 67
offers later
and the anonymous buyer walked away with
the item item for record 2.25
million dollars the card is one of the
only 100 ever made and uh
was previously purchased on ebay over a
decade ago when it remained in a private
collection before being sold think about
it guy bought this on ebay
over a decade ago keeps it doesn't do
anything 10 years later puts an
auction sells it for 2.25 million
dollars
the rare item received an eight and a
half grade and a
nine on the signature broke a record
prior record was uh 1.2 million
of also tom brady uh and then you also
have the super super mario brothers
game can you pull up the picture here
super mario brothers game
unopened so for 660 from 1986
type in super mario mario and then just
type um
uh unopened type in unopened there you
go
uh open box yeah click on that let's see
if it comes up
660. can you type in 660 thousand
dollars
660. yeah type in right there let's see
what comes up
go to news no no go to all all all
yeah uh there you go right there go to
the second one cnn
yeah uh
that's it look at that that sold for
660.
that right there so for 660
thousand dollars just because it's
unopened
it got a grade of 9.6 so again you can't
duplicate that you either have it or you
don't have it
and somebody may say what a stupid thing
to own yeah
but it's unopened from 1986 which is how
many years ago
35 years ago someone sees value in that
so
you may have some things you're buying
right now that no one's paying attention
to sit on it for a little while
see what happens that's where i was
going with this is a similar theme here
you said sit on it i say buy and hold so
or as my crypto friends will say
buy and hodl you've seen that before
yeah so
uh good things take time so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye